a lo largo de su vida matemática quizás
ustedes estén acostumbrados a trabajar
con los números reales números reales
que ejemplos hay de números reales pues
casi todos los que se les puedan ocurrir
por ejemplo 0 1 esté 0.33 periódicos
0.33 periódicos o pi o quizás todos
estos son ejemplos de números reales y
después lo que hicimos fue decir bueno
imaginemos que tenemos un número y que
se llama la unidad imaginaria que tiene
la particularidad de que si lo elevó al
cuadrado y al cuadrado
esto me da menos 1 entonces con eso se
nos abrió la puerta a otro tipo de
números que son los números imaginarios
imaginarios
y en qué consiste en estos números
imaginarios pues son múltiplos reales de
esta unidad y de esta unidad imaginaria
así que tendríamos por ejemplo 1 x y que
sería lo mismo que iu o 0.33 periódico x
y opi por i
y todos estos son ejemplos de números
imaginarios y bueno ustedes podrían
pensar qué pasa si ahora los combinó si
tomo un número que tenga una parte real
y una parte imaginaria y esos se llaman
números complejos y son de los que trata
este vídeo así que imaginemos que
tenemos un número z un número complejo
de hecho z es la variable que más
frecuentemente aparece cuando están
trabajando con números complejos pero
bueno vamos a pensar que z es no sé 5
más 3 x
53 por iu y quizás estén tentados a
tratar de simplificar esto a tratar de
sumar este 5 con este 3 o no sé pero
vamos a ver que realmente no puedes
hacer eso que en realidad podemos pensar
en estos dos números como yendo en
direcciones distintas lo explico más en
un segundo lo importante es que en este
número en z igual a 53 y lo que tengo es
una parte real esto es mi parte real
y una parte imaginaria esto es mi parte
imaginaria
imaginad
ok este 5 es el número real y 3 y es un
número imaginario ahora al veces verán
esta anotación la parte real de z la
parte real pues simplemente es el 5 y
también tenemos la parte imaginaria de
zeta
en este caso y aquí es donde hay que
tener cuidado no sería 3 y si no
simplemente sería 3 es como que múltiplo
de la unidad imaginaria tengo pues tengo
tres veces la unidad imaginaria así que
solo sería el 3 y vamos a pensar en esto
un poco más gráficamente que les parece
así como tenemos a los números reales en
una recta podría pensar en los números
complejos como un plano como un plano un
plano cartesiano habitual en el que el
eje y lo voy a notar con por el eje
imaginario y el eje x lo voy a notar
como el eje real y lo que voy a hacer es
graficar precisamente la parte real y la
parte imaginaria así que por ejemplo
para z que es 53 y tengo que la parte
real es 5
así que veamos
1 2 3 4 5 5 unidades hacia acá y luego
tengo que la parte imaginaria vale 3 así
que uno dos tres y de este modo aquí
tendría el número complejo z
esta sería z mejor luego en azul también
esto sería z que es el número 5 + 3 y
puedo graficar en sí cualquier número
que yo quiera en esto que se llama el
plano complejo el plano complejo plano
o también frecuentemente lo llamaré el
plano de arganda
pero bueno podría aquí graficar el
número complejo que a mí se me antoje
por ejemplo podría poner
qué color usar este podría decir que a
es igual el número complejo menos dos
más y entonces dónde lo gráfica haría
pues tengo que la parte real es menos 2
así que
a todos menos dos y la parte imaginaria
pues puedo pensar está ahí como uno por
y así que la parte imaginaria vale uno
el número complejo estaría
aproximadamente por aquí esto de que
sería o también podría pensar en incluso
qué les parece el número b que va a ser
cuatro menos 3 y 4 menos tres y dónde
iría pues veamos la parte real es 4 1 2
3 4 y bajo 3 unidades 1 2 3 unidades así
que este punto de aquí sería el número
complejo b